and then the greatest thing is when you
start crossing things off your list
right right you're like wow I didn't
know where that for example I I wanted
to you know I wanted to go to Russia
I didn't no idea how I was gonna get to
Russia and darn I just came back from
Russia you know so it things manifest
like you you don't even know where
they're coming from
but so we were talking about writer's
block what I've learned about this this
bubble excitable Eve so strongly in it
is that so much of writer's block and so
much of incompletions incomplete
projects come from the inability to deal
with other people's opinions I am NOT a
big fan of writers groups where you're
giving opinions on all on everyone's
projects yet the the the ability to hang
on to your own to your own identity and
the belief in the power of your own
identity is so much more the path to
success the path to getting everything
you want when you start asking for too
many for other people's reflections on
your work and start asking for
validation or Direction don't go back
inward inward find your core find your
strength it's the time for feedback is
when you feel so good about your project
and you you will be able to discern the
good feedback from the bad feedback
you'll be able to hear oh this person's
just talking about their own work that
this they're reacting to their to
something that's triggered them or
they're trying to give me their person
their personal opinion because they they
feel strongly about something that I've
written but it doesn't work for my story
right there's there's a power that when
you come into the marketplace and you're
ready for feedback
that you're able to say that's good
feedback oh that makes my story better
oh I can see how that's a great twist or
or even I may not agree with them but I
can see how their opinion would make my
story different and I might go there
so it's this centeredness that you want
to go out in the marketplace with and
until you have that centeredness you're
going to be whipped around like a like a
like a you know like again that hamster
in a little hamster wheel trying to
chase people's approval and it's you you
can't succeed that way and it'll it'll
demoralize you so we often hear someone
say hey I just finished a second draft
of something can I send it to you for
your review or even a short film do you
recommend people do that because at some
point we need to see it some from
another set of eyes because our own are
very biased to what we do we all need
feedback we end and a Peter my partner
of many years has always given me great
feedback but the difference is how you
stand within the feedback so if you're
if the desire for feedback comes from
wanting someone to fix what you have or
wanting someone to approve of you or
wanting someone to to validate that
you're talented or validate that you're
gonna succeed or validate that you have
a good idea you're asking for trouble
it's so much more valuable if you can
imagine that what you write and what you
create is like a child and in its
wholeness
it has unity and strength and value in
the world now in the same way you would
not look at a toddler
and deem it that it's going to you will
never make money in banking sit down go
back to the you know get back to where
you came from I never do that you have
to appreciate that that child and the
city is is gonna learn things and you're
gonna want to to teach it Spanish or
you're gonna want to to have it develop
its talents but you have to approach it
as if as if it has value in itself if if
you start rearranging the elements of
the story in this in a way that destroys
the wholeness of the child you've just
birthed you're gonna be frustrated and
go back to square one I've just seen so
many writers because we both teach
storytelling really be willing to
rearrange anything because somebody with
authority has told them to and even
though that person with authority may be
very smart they may be a studio
executive they may be a brilliant story
coach they may be a producer
you're still the guide of this child
that you've created and if you don't
know your own work and your own path for
this and believe in it as it is you're
you could end up in development hell for
another five years trying to please
someone who doesn't really know what
they want because they're chasing the
marketplace they're not really
interested in the integrity of your work
so it's a balance
it's a balance but it it absolutely
comes first and foremost with with the
strong core of knowing how good you are
how unique your voices and the the
ability to to hold your Center
you